hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to do the third in my series which
i call the language learning tripod
uh the first one was uh to have the
right attitude that that's key and i
went into some detail about the kind of
attitude you need to have
the second one was to spend enough time
but even if you spend enough time and if
you are motivated you have to learn to
notice and i think that is what
distinguishes
um not so successful language learners
from successful language learners we
have to notice now speaking of noticing
someone said what is that map
uh you know on the back wall there so
i'll tell you it's a back it's a map of
la nouvel france or canada sometime in
the 17th century
um what do we have here
canada
there you have it it shows
uh you know what is quebec the great
lakes
uh parts of new england uh somewhere in
the 17th century so
that's for the person who noticed the
map
noticing all right when we start a new
language everything is a blur we don't
notice much the words seem to flow
together
everything is strange
how do we get to the point
where we convert this into something
that's meaningful for us we obviously
need to develop that capability in the
brain to treat this as a language
much as the brain already treats our
native language or other languages that
we know as something that is converted
easily into meaning
so
to me
i find i think this is going to be
individual for different people so i can
only talk about what works for me
the most important thing that enables me
to start noticing the language is simply
lots of exposure if i can guarantee
myself that i listen a lot and read a
lot
i will gradually start to notice more
and more because
the language just becomes more and more
familiar to me now people say how can
you listen to something you don't
understand well i've explained many
times
i start with with short things i start
with things where i either have a
translation
or i actually prefer
to do it as we do it at link not
surprisingly and that is to look up the
individual words
personally i find the translation or the
bilingual text distracting
but other people love doing it that way
so you know this is not this is good
this is bad it's a matter of what works
for you individually i like the idea
that
you know it's much like a link when we
start a new
uh language all the words are
highlighted in blue
as i go through and pick out the words
that i need to learn they convert to
yellow and then i can get rid of all the
other blue words in that text
convert them to white and once a word is
converted to yellow or white whenever
that word appears again it'll be yellow
or white so then i can focus more and
more on the words that i don't know
uh
once i have saved a word then i can
review it in flashcards i don't do a lot
of flashcarding but when i do i'm
looking for
i'm looking to train my brain to the
relationships between words the
components that reappear in different
words and so very often when i do
flashcards i have the
the foreign word and the english
translation
and the phrase that we capture all on
the front i'm just looking at them i'm
going through quickly i don't want to
challenge my brain to try to remember it
personally i don't find that that works
for me what works for me is exposure so
i review them quickly and try to see if
i can train my brain to see
the connections between different words
uh when i read at link because the words
that i previously saved are highlighted
in yellow i find that that helps to
remind me that i've looked it up of
course i can see the meaning and so it's
just this constant exposure and all of a
sudden lo and behold
words that i couldn't remember and
couldn't remember i see them in more and
more different contexts
i start to notice them now the more
language learning is a bit like a jigsaw
puzzle the more of the pieces you have
in place
the more
new things that used to just go flying
by you that you didn't notice now you
start to notice now another thing that
helps you notice obviously is to read
some description of the frequently
occurring patterns in the language or a
grammatical explanation but i've also
found that
a grammatical explanation that i read
at an early stage
it doesn't have much impact on me but at
a later stage once i have already
kind of seen that pattern then if i read
the grammatical explanation it helps me
notice it again
and words that i have tried to remember
i'll try to
uh or that i've worked in my flash cards
on or that i know that these are
important words for me when i hear them
then i try to make a mental note that
i've i've heard them
i always like to listen to whatever i
read and read whatever i listen to
because i find that that reinforcing
also helps me notice things
with regard to pronunciation we have to
be very careful not to allow
our native language
and particularly the writing system in
our native language to influence
how we what we hear
so if we are
uh say a spanish speaker where the
phonetic
uh you know the alphabet is very
phonetical
and so every word always has the same
um uh sound in spanish so if we come to
english and we see a word like word
w-o-r-d word
bird b-i-r-d
heard
h-e-a-r-d we have to start noticing that
it doesn't matter how those words are
written in fact they're all pronounced
the same so we need that deliberate
attempt to start noticing these kinds of
things and so you train yourself to
notice you get better the more you're
into the language and of course the more
languages you know
the easier it is to notice because you
are already familiar with similar
patterns in other languages particularly
if there are related languages so it's
easier to notice
how they might differ in the new
language or or how they might be the
same so it's this this old
adage the sufi sufist adage i often
mention this you can only learn what you
already know but really what that means
is
you know once you notice something or
maybe it's pointed out to you then you
have a better chance of noticing it the
next time and the more you notice things
the more likely it is it's event that
the more likely it is to eventually
stick so to me language learning is a
matter of noticing and frequently
noticing and that in this way eventually
things stick in the brain
much more so than deliberately trying to
memorize something which i have found
not so effective
uh yeah mistakes here's another one when
you speak or write when you are
corrected to me
if i am corrected or if i correct
someone else i don't expect that that
person that i corrected or the person
who corrected me will enable me to get
it right the next time correction is not
about getting it right the next time
correction is about
making you start to notice and so by
pointing it out
i know yeah yeah but i'll still get it
wrong the next time but if it's pointed
out again and maybe i start to notice
uh when i'm listening
slowly
there's a chance that my brain will
start to pick up on this because the
brain is trying to create rules and
establish patterns so that it can deal
with this you know new experience which
is the new new
language so there are these things that
you can do
to help the brain
let's see i made some notes i don't
always make some notes here to help the
brain
notice all right so there you have it i
mean it's it's it's individual it's the
key
uh
learning skill
noticing
because you have to condition your brain
to the new language once you have these
words in you that they're part of that
system then to actually
develop the skill of speaking and
writing and understanding is going to
flow from that because if you've noticed
all these things and you've built up the
vocabulary and you've noticed
these different structures and you've
noticed the pronunciation so they become
really
a part of how you use the language it's
now starting to fall into place now if
you want to develop the skill to speak
better you have all the elements in
place so my advice is
focus on deliberately noticing
be concerned about your ability to
notice
don't get upset if you read a rule
grammar rule and forget it if you are
corrected and make the same mistake
again
if you study a list of words and can't
remember them
if you're reading in the same places are
still difficult to understand none of
that matters because the sheer fact of
doing those things is gradually and
deliberate is
unmistakably going to enable your brain
to start noticing these things
and your task is to expose the brain to
enough stimulus both in the form of the
language and some of these other
activities that it starts to notice and
once it starts to notice it'll build for
you a whole control center for the new
language so just to summarize the three
here you've got to be positive about the
language you have to like the language i
think your emotional relationship to the
language is extremely important to
learning it you've got to be confident
about your own ability
uh
you know you got to like the task you
don't want to get frustrated at yourself
all of these
attitude factors are extremely important
the second thing was time it takes time
the brain learns all the time but the
brain learns slowly so if you are
serious about learning the language you
have to put in the time and put the time
in enjoyably and efficiently in whatever
activities you find enjoyable and
efficient for you and then the third
issue was this developing the ability to
notice initially through just a lot of
exposure a lot of listening and reading
and speaking
and then
taking advantage of when a mistake is
pointed out
or you're skimming through a grammar
book or you're flipping through some
flash cards
realize that these things are helping
you to notice and be a little bit
deliberate in that you want to notice
when you're listening oh yeah there was
that or when you're reading like i'll
often underline a phrase because i know
i consistently get it wrong and all of
this is sending signals to your brain
that's going to help your brain notice
not only the details of the language but
put together sort of a comprehensive
control center for the language
so there you have it i think that
language learning is essentially quite a
simple concept
those are the three elements your
attitude
the ability to enjoy your commitment
your connection to the language the time
you put in and then developing this
ability to notice so i look forward to
any questions bye for now